hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of this year's Super bet chess
classic I was uh thinking about showing
you the game Fabiano caruana versus the
rehab rapper because Fabi went into the
final round with half a point lead ahead
of um uh the pack however that game
ended in a fairly quick draw uh it was
uh sort of uh uh you know uh heating up
to be a very exciting game because the
reports uh prepared a very very uh
interesting line that Fabi already
played against Magnus Carlsen in the
2019 Grand Swiss Grand Swiss tournament
uh but uh Fabi neutralized the thread
very well even though Robert found an
improvement on the line that Magnus
played uh but then like very quickly it
um all ended up in a draw so this means
that if fabi's game ended ends in a draw
a niche who was trailing by half a point
uh now has a chance to win tie breaks
against Fabi but he has to defeat uh
janiponishi so let's see what happens in
this game and did he get this chance to
fight far before for first place in the
super bet chess Classic Tournament so
here uh Anish has the white pieces and
he opens with Ponte E4 sorry about that
uh nipple goes for his Sicilian waveform
to C5 Knight to F3 we have Knight to the
east uh Pawn D6 and pawn to D4 striking
in the center captures captures Knight
to F6 Knight to C3 and now Knight the C6
and here we have Knight D to B5
um uh countering the timana variation uh
with this um uh sort of a old school uh
Anderson Type move uh we have Pawn to D6
and now Bishop to F4 uh we're putting
more pressure on this D6 Pawn we have
pawned the E5 and now just Bishop to G5
um uh transferring into the the
sashnikov variation uh if you're
thinking about Knight the D5 going for
Knights the C7 which sort of resembles
something that morphy played against
Anderson long long time ago here it
doesn't work because black just captures
on D5 and there there's nothing here but
it it is a fairly simple a similar
structure only in that game the Knight
wasn't developed and the pawn was played
to F5 so here Bishop to G5 we have Pawn
to A6 Knights the A3 and now Pawn to B5
repairing Pawn to B4 so usually people
just play Knights the D5 here as the
Knight on f60 spin so you want to attack
it or you even capture on F6 and then
play Knights to D5 but here uh Anish
prepared something special he wants to
play for a full point here he plays
Knight a to B1 and okay it's not a new
move of course it has been played before
we have Bishop D7 uh here he trades on
F6 captures captures and pawn to A4 now
nipple the advances the pawn to B4
Knights the D5 now puts pressure on the
bishop
and again a lot of moves were played
here Bishop to G5 is the normal Bishop
D7 is a normal just castling is a normal
here but Nepal plays Bishop to E6 and it
is now as of move at 13 that we have a
completely new game so okay Bishop to C4
unleash continues development uh both
players Castle so castles castles and
the bishop to G5 now not allowing this
um uh Knight to be traded for Bishop but
also it just it's just a very useful
Bush pen this diagonal also makes it
harder for white to execute F4 so here
we have Queen to D3 uh and King to AJ
never wants to get his King off of this
diagonal and with this move he's
basically announcing that he is ready to
play F5 at some point we have knighted
the D2 and now while everyone thought
okay F5 is coming he actually plays
Bishop captures on D2 he says uh the the
the Knight might become more powerful
than the bishop so he trades it Queen
captures and now Queen to A5 you have to
defend the B4 Pawn so C3 3 challenges
the B4 pawn and now Queen to C5 puts
pressure on the bishop here Bishop to A2
and now B captures and C3 sorry not
Bishop to E2 Bishop to a tube B captures
on C3 B captures and now Knights the A5
getting ready to put that Knight on C4
uh Rook 8 to B1 and now Pawn to H6 not
allowing any uh infiltrating moves with
Queen to G5 so not just Rook to B4 as uh
nipple weighted with Knight to C4 now
Anish has sufficient control over the C4
Square rookate the B8 contesting the
rook and the v file and of course now
Queen to D3 going after the A6 Pawn nepo
defends it Queen to A7 and now quanta H3
just creating some breathing room for
the king Here and Now Knights the B7 and
this is a beautiful move that nipple uh
very often finds with um a little
investment of time he just wants to
re-maneuver the knights the C5 and his
position uh seems to have drastically
improved in the uh in just a little bit
so here Ponte A5 Knight the C5 attacks
the queen and queen back to E2 we have
rooked the B5 now uh and Rook capture
Sun B5 it's a pawn sacrifice but uh you
will see why it captures Queen captures
on B5 and now while you could capture an
E4 first Rook to B8 attacks the queen
queen back to E2 and only now Queen
captures on A5 winning back your
material with Bishop to C4 and now Queen
to A3 uh just going uh active with the
queen Now The Rook is coming to B2 to
put pressure on the queen here uh you
could also consider Bishop captures on
D5 for example Bishop captures Queen
captures and C3 but then Bishop captures
an F7 so you don't really win a pawn uh
so you have to avoid that so Queen day 3
was played Queen to F3 and now King the
H7 uh we we have Rook D1 adding another
Defender here and queen to B2 we have
rooked D1 now and Rook the A8 now
preparing to bring the Rook into the
game maybe Rook day to if the bishop
moves or even just Rook the A1 uh just
the trade of the pair of Rooks so here
we have Knight D3 and the immediate Rook
to A1 we have Bishop captures on E6 F
characters and now Knights the C4
putting pressure on the D6 Pawn uh so
Rook captures on D1 with check Queen
captors and queen captures and C3 we
have Knight captures on D6 uh and now uh
uh how do you continue here well
Knight's the D3 anisha's Knights are
very active the material is equal and
each does have the doubled Pawn here but
shouldn't really be an issue as his
pieces are very much active sorry
nipples pieces are very much active but
Anish says my pieces will become active
as well he plays Knights the E8 and
already you can see some dangers here
maybe uh you know the black king gets
checkmated so here we have Queen to D4
just threatening the F2 Pawn forcing a
niche to deal with that Queen to E2 and
now Knights the F4 attacks the queen
here Queen to C2 and here Nepal plays
Queen to A1 with check uh the real
attempt here was Queen to d8 uh it's
such a nice move that attacks the Knight
here and now okay Queen to C2 had to be
played in order to be able to retreat
the Knight to C7 but now Queen G5 would
threaten Checkmate and you would have to
defend with G3 or F3 but regardless of
how you defend uh you would have to give
up a pawn Knight captures an H3 with
checking H2 Knight F4 once again and now
the queen is stuck here guarding the G2
Pawn so G3 and now okay Queen to H5
checking to G1 you can go Knight to H3
with check uh King to G2 and now for
example Knight G5 threatening some
infiltrating ideas here but it seems
that after a queen to F2 white does hold
this position it's very tricky to play
and black is up a pawn but you hold for
example Queen H3 King to G1 and
everything is fine uh but uh it was
avoided by nepo he played Queen to A1
check as he found a different uh idea a
one particular idea
you know that has something to do with
Checkmate so here King the H2 Queen to
F1 now threatening Checkmate and now
just Pawn to F3 stopping Checkmate the
queen now guards the G2 pawn and now
nipple thought okay probably I have
Knights the E2 and then I'm just gonna
Checkmate the white thing the problem is
there's Queen to C5 this stops Checkmate
and also I mean it's just very strong
Queen can come to A7 you can also
threaten Checkmate on G7 so uh this is
something that nepo definitely missed
but nepo finds a ways to continue
um uh you know muddying up the water so
here Ponte H5 Knights the D6 Anish now
brings the Knight into the game Quinta
E1 now preparing H4 and queen to G3
check we have Knights the B5 and Ponte
H4 and hiron is just plays Knights the
D6 he says all right there's nothing
here let's just call it a day but the
position is actually completely winning
for Yan uh so feel free to pause the
video here and win the game for nepo uh
well I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
wild idea and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is night the E2
the same idea that didn't work a few
moves ago and now it works because the
pawn is an H4 and now look at this queen
to C5 uh and now uh nipple throws the
win away uh at least for the moment
because here he should have continued
Queen to G3 check
um uh the the reason why it's so strong
is that uh after King to H1 and queen to
F4 going for Knight to G3 check there's
no good defense let's say queen to C2
Knight to G3 check King to G1 uh or King
the H2 you could also go under the mask
of the of the queen and then just Knight
to F5 check picks up the Knight and of
course if you don't go at H2 if you go
King to G1 then there's Queen to E3 with
check King to H2 and not just Queen to
E1 with an unavoidable Checkmate sorry
for some reason my camera decided to
reset itself so after Queen the C5
Knight the G3 was played instead now
threatening Checkmate but now I need to
just Place Queen to G1 and no more
Checkmate so here Knight to F1 check was
played King to H1 now comes Queen to C1
with check and now Knights the B7 uh
preparing to bring the Knight back into
the game Knights the G3 check King H2
and now Queen to F4 again threatening
some very nasty ideas like Knight
captures and E4 and okay if you grab
this Pawn could be a little bit
dangerous But Here Comes Queen to B1 and
absolutely spectacular move by a niche
uh saying that you have no continuation
here the problem with this captures uh
with a discover check is King to H1 and
now the white king the White Knight is
lost you can't move it the king is on H7
so after this queen to B1 move King to
H6 was played by nipple there are no
good discoveries here and now just King
to G1 uh sidestepping this um a nasty
check Queen to D2 now just King back to
H2 we have Knights the E2 but now just
Queen to A1 keeping the the tension
putting pressure on the pawn here point
the F4 with check King to H1 Knights the
G3 check again King to G1 and now Queen
to E3 with checking back to H2 Queen to
B6 now putting pressure on the Knight
but not just Queen to C1 check winning
the C5 Square so the King has to move
Knight to C5 the Knight now returns to
the game with Knight to the E2 and queen
to E1 just offering a trade of knights
and then of course uh a queen and pawn
end game will be a dead draw so here we
have Knights the G3 but now Knights to
D3 with Queen to B5 putting pressure on
the Knight Knight the F2 and now Knights
the F1 with check we have King the G one
Knights the G3 Knight a king stage two
Knight to F1 check King G1 Knight to G3
King to H2 and he was in this position
on move 68 that Anish and nepo agreed to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done here uh the problem is uh or rather
it's already a three-fold repetition so
a remarkable game where Anisha really
tried everything to win nipple also had
a winning um chance but he but he
blundered it but also the problem for
Anish was that if he doesn't uh draw
this game if he loses this game he also
loses like 20 21 000 so that's the
difference of uh in the standings in the
grand Chester uh between between him
actually drawing or or winning this game
so yeah good for him that he he drew the
game and uh Fabi is the winner of the of
the event he wins the 100 000 first
prize and that's it for this classical
event if you guys are interested we
could also show the dinga game uh but
that's basically it the players as I
understand it will remain in Romania the
super bet um uh chess rapid and Blitz
will start I believe in some three or
four days so we're gonna enjoy some
quick chess as well uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh uh Fabi
couldn't uh pull through against the
rapper but Rapport is incredibly well
prepared he of course was the dean's
second for the world championship match
so it was uh you know the game could
have exploded game it could have gone
either way but it just ended up being a
quick draw but here really exciting
stuff between Anisha and nepo but in the
end both players having their chances
just ends up being a draw so there we
have it hope you guys enjoyed it a brief
overview of the superbet chess classic I
would like to thank masi and elsarak Dr
Heisenberg ding fan revision reptiles
YouTube and human
Resa for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of uh um uh
the the super bet uh chess tournament
and checking up on your suggestions and
everything else that happens in the
Chess World so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day